- I wanna bring up the inspiration,
like your inspiration with
the fashion you've used.
I wanna bring up those
pictures once again.
This, I remember this first one, I think.
Were you at the Oscars right there?
- [Billy] Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- The Oscars was really
where it popped off.
There was a Golden Globe before that,
which was my first time
on a major red carpet.
- Yeah.
- But when the Oscars
called, I knew, you know,
this is the entertainment Super Bowl.
My friend Idina Menzel, a few years prior,
you know, her name was
said wrong, and I saw.
- We all saw.
- Adele Dazine.
- Yeah.
- And then she became a
household name because of that.
And the businessman inside
of me was like, well, what,
when ABC called to ask me
to be on the red carpet,
I said, "Well, what is my
wrong name calling gonna be?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, what is it?
- Yeah, what will be memorable,
but also have a message?
- Absolutely.
- When I saw that dress, I was like,
"Well, hell, I'd wear that."
Like, I love that.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And my thought was, you know,
because I used to always say when I was
at Carnegie Mellon Drama School,
we would have Oscar parties
and I would be like,
"I'm not gonna wear that penguin suit.
"I'm gonna wear a gown.
"I'm gonna wear a gown."
And it's interesting
because words do have power.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Even when you're not conscious of it.
So, 30 years later, 25
years later, whatever,
I'm asked to do this thing.
And I was like, oh, I remember
I said I was gonna wear
a gown to the Oscars.
And so, I got to Christian Siriano
and I thought, well, if it starts.
- I love him.
- If the shot starts here
and it looks like just
a traditional tuxedo
and then when you pull
out, it's a full gag.
- I know.
- It'll change the world.
- Because there's more than just the top.
- Yes.
- You know what I'm saying?
There's more to a person
than even one outfit.
I love it.
I'm not that into fashion.
That's why I love watching it.
'Cause I don't innately go,
I am like the person you hate.
I wear like workout clothes every day
and I don't work out in them.
(Billy laughing)
It's like, look, they're comfortable
- Athleisure.
- It seems practical.
I am 100% athleisure.
- And you have two children.
- I know.
- And athleisure is cool now.
- I would love to blame
it on the children.
I was this on tour before, yeah.
I've always with this person,
but I love watching it.
You know, I'm not a
painter, but I love art.
I love all of that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.